every gaming peripheral company will
tell you that their product is the best
they'll all say that their stuff will
give you some type of advantage that
their competitors won't they'll claim
that their Creations are faster lighter
have better battery life the list goes
on so would you believe me if I told you
that there is allegedly a keyboard out
there that can legitimately make you
better at games like Counter-Strike and
valorant that's exactly what wooting are
claiming they've created some of the
industry's fastest most Innovative
boards and many Pros have already made
the switch but is it true can their
boards actually give you an edge over
your opponents try to try to stall this
M80 hit out
oh
he dodged it oh my God what an accident
what's this rooting settings
[Applause]
all right so a few months back we made a
video about corsair's k-100 air
unexpensive Wireless ultra thin keyboard
that certainly looked interesting
instead our entire comment section was
flooded with messages begging us to test
out some looting keyboards and today we
are going to do exactly that but before
we do that I'm sure there are those of
you who are wondering
who the hell hooting are back in 2015
three friends in the Netherlands decided
that they wanted to make analog
keyboards the industry standard
mechanical switches use digital inputs
which essentially means that when you're
not touching them they're off and when
you are pressing them they're on but
analog switches are able to send
variable inputs to your PC based on how
much pressure you're applying to the
switch you can almost think of it like a
joystick on a controller the more
pressure you apply the faster your
character moves it measures exactly how
far down you press a key for analog
input opening up an entire new input
dimension for keyboards and PC gaming as
you can see right now in The Witcher
free wild Hunt I can control exactly how
fast I want to move analog switches have
the potential to offer drastic
improvements for competitive Gamers
video editors and even audio Engineers
so so rooting's initial announcement
garnered tons of hype fast forward a
couple years and the wooting one hit
consumer hands in August of 2017. aside
from some software related issues for
the most part users were happy with
their purchase and they released a
full-size keyboard the following year
but they weren't done there wooting
wanted to improve on their initial
Creations so in May of 2019 they
announced their own switch unlike normal
switches lacquer linear switches have a
magnet on the stem and react to the hall
effect sensor on wooting's pcbs which
gives you a full range of analog inputs
from zero to four millimeters actuation
their next couple of releases
implemented these switches but over the
past few years custom keyboards have
exploded in popularity more and more
people have started participating in
this very expensive hobby customizing
every aspect of their board to suit
their particular meets with many of them
building boards in smaller cases so the
next logical step for wooting was a 60
keyboard they crushed their initial
production goal of 75 000 Euros raising
over 250
000 Euros from nearly 1300 contributors
and once everyone got their hands on the
60 the he Midway through last year the
consensus seemed to be that wooting
really created something special pretty
much every Tech reviewer was praising it
and calling it the best keyboard on the
market the whole experience here with
the wording PCB and the you know inputs
that feel this good I don't think that
there's any custom keyboard out there
that could make me switch off of this
setup for gaming overall I think what we
have here is probably the best gaming
keyboard you can buy right now like I
said in the beginning this is hands down
the best gaming keyboard out there and
the hype surrounding 60 he only grew
when some of the biggest names in
valorant and CS go began using it I
remember the first time I saw it was yay
using it on a land like forgot what it
was Masters or Champs or something but
um
ever since then like everyone's like on
the hype because
just because of how fast everything
registers and unveiling like every every
jiggle matters like everything matters
so
um I can definitely see more people
switching I already see a lot of people
buying it and trying it and using it
and uh I mean I think it's only up from
there for them so since plenty of top
tack FPS Pros have already made the
switch to wooting in the last couple
years we thought it was time for us to
test it out and see what all the hype
was about thankfully wooting were kind
enough to send our valorant loving
writer Nile a 60 he to test out and
here's what he had to say about it and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about all right so first off I
just want to say a huge thank you to Wu
Tang for sending me a 60 he to test out
this video isn't sponsored so as always
I'm just here to share my honest opinion
on the product it ships with the
keyboard a wrist strap keycap puller and
a couple spare switches it also comes
with this really wholesome postcard that
says you can write down a favor and
Wu-Tang will do their best to make it
happen I haven't done that yet but it's
a nice little Personal Touch from wujing
anyways before I began playing around
with the keyboard my biggest worry was
that it wouldn't sound as good as the
custom that I built last year and it
doesn't that being said for a pre-built
gaming keyboard it still sounds
surprisingly good I honestly think that
it sounds better than almost any other
pre-built the stabilizers sound better
than expected but they could definitely
still use a little bit of work
moving on the setup on the 60 he is
fairly intuitive with Wu Tang's utility
software which you can download or you
can just use the web-based version this
allows you to set up a pile of lighting
effects you can also create profiles and
set the actuation point of each
individual key to meet your specific
needs but if you're unsure of how to set
this properly then I recommend checking
out wu-tang's Discord server there's a
lot of great info in there and a lot of
people who are willing to share their
profiles for different games I even
imported ethos's valorent profile just
so I had a starting point before making
my own settings but to start things off
I just wanted to see how responsive the
Wu-Tang could feel so I set the
actuation to 0.1 millimeters and turned
on rapid trigger and tachyama Rapid
trigger allows you to set just how fast
your keys reset as you start releasing
pressure from the switch and tachyon
mode gives you sub 1 millisecond input
latency at the expense of the RGB
effects but honestly I really don't care
about RGB effects I don't even have them
on my custom board the difference in
speed compared to my own keyboard was
pretty drastic strafing from side to
side felt noticeably more responsive and
seeing my character move faster based on
how far I was pressing down on the key
helped me visualize the benefits of a
fully analog keyboard but the experience
that I had even just in the range on
valorant felt weird it was honestly a
little too responsive for me with
everything on the fastest settings it's
pretty easy to fat finger your abilities
or any keys that you might be hovering
your fingers over like your space bar or
shift key and to be fair I sort of
expected this but I wanted to try it
anyways so I went back into utility set
my wasd keys to the lowest actuation at
0.1 millimeters and all other keys to
one and then set rapid trigger so it
only affected my movement Keys as well
this pretty much solved my initial
problem my movement still felt very
fluid but I wasn't fat fingering random
Keys anymore it took me a few games to
really get used to the feel of it but
once I did I understood why every Pro is
switching to this keyboard having
precise control over your movement can
give you an edge over your opponent when
jiggle peaking and counter-stripping I
don't think that a weedsing keyboard on
its own will take an iron player and
suddenly make them plot or turn in a
mortal player Radio but for professional
players who rely on these low latency
inputs it's probably worth it when it
comes to valorant or CS go
um tactical FPS shooters were the
difference of a few milliseconds uh can
be the difference between like being
accurate or inaccurate or being alive or
being dead and which ultimately can
result in winning the round or winning
the game so it makes sense that you'd
want to you know just optimize those
variables as much as possible the only
thing that I'm not a huge fan of is the
plastic case because my custom Wilton
and aluminum back in Nico and feels a
lot more sturdy but the great thing
about the 60hg is that you could always
take the PCB and switches and Transplant
them into another case and then just
throw different keycaps on them plenty
of people have already proven just how
easy it is to mod so I I lubed it I did
a spring swap with lighter springs I
replaced the
um like the what's it called the case so
it's an aluminum case I added a tape mod
I did a burger mount
what the did I not do I did like
everything there is to do
I quite literally modded the out of
this thing for 175 US dollars I think
the Wu-Tang 60 he is an excellent option
for anyone who takes games like valorant
or Counter-Strike seriously there are of
course benefits to using this keyboard
with other games hell I was even using
it for old school RuneScape but the
movement advantage that it offers in Tac
FPS games is what really makes it
special in my eyes after three weeks of
using it I'm still impressed and I
genuinely don't think I can go back to
my normal custom mechanical keyboard
honestly I might just buy my own
personal booting and just mod the
out of it like tens because once I get
it to sound better then I think the 60
he will be perfect for me and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so I guess that makes it
pretty clear why tons of Pros are using
this keyboard it's I'm a powerful tool
for top Tech FPS players and with
massive content creators also jumping to
booting this keyboard is pretty close to
becoming the gold standard everywhere
it's like the new it's like the new
thing it's like the it's like the
Artisan mouse pads you know like whether
or not like it's actually like
gonna make a difference or not like it's
just what's hot so all the pros are
using right it's like when the ec2 is
hot when the super light was hot you
look at gear for gamers and it's like
how much better can we get before it
becomes negligible and just like a fun
you know pretty thing on your desk but
this sounds like this type of Technology
of responsive key clicks and pressure
kind of the amount of pressure is the
feedback you can set those settings to
how much you need to press or whatever
sounds amazing and I I'm really
interested in their technology but
unfortunately I haven't got to try it
yet bootings rise within the peripheral
space changed everything it made other
brands reconsider what Hardware they
were using in their boards and helped
push the industry forward despite not
even being out that long the 60 he has
already become an indispensable piece of
tech within the Esports world one that
simply cannot be ignored so if you're a
pro or just anyone who takes their love
of TAC FPS seriously it might be time to
consider making the switch
yeah I mean I'd also like to take this
time to tell everybody to please clean
your keyboards like use a use a keycap
puller and clean that every once in
a while like I've seen some disgusting
keyboards lately just disgusters oh God
yeah don't remind me I just legit I was
like that is
so gross
like I I get there's like dust but
there's like some people have it where
it looks like there's like a character
right out of it yeah
physically said like I'm like I'm gonna
throw up how do you like let it get to
that point